we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk yeah
hey folks we might be drunk here we are
back to the day drinking i mean it's
pretty early again yeah this
podcast is a literally an enabler it's
it's
opening my eyes to what might be a
problem
yeah we did one the other day i was on
two hours of sleep and then i
left the pod after having a couple
guinnesses and went straight to a
three-hour car ride
road beers two shows drink it during the
shows
ari dina vekione james madden
drove back drinking beers it was just
like a wild night
damn are you hurting right now no i'm
okay cause i spread it out
that's how you do it that's how you do
it kids spread out
you can do eight to twelve beers if you
do it over a long period of time
and that took years of failing and
learning and trial and error but
uh i got i had a nice three beer buzz
throughout the day
that's a good buzz i remember i had that
coach when i was like seventh eighth
grade he was he was a dude who was like
you can drink just make sure you have a
slice of pizza before soak up the booze
yes i'd like to pick to the guy with a
whistle and the stripes the black and
white
have a piece of pizza get a water in you
all right the chug chug chug
it was that he was such a funny guy he
was the type of guy who would be like he
would say something like he would just
like say [ __ ] up [ __ ] like about jews
blacks anyone and he was like
he goes oh i'm racist i went to memphis
i i played baseball 14 black guys
10 whites and a jew me
like that's how we defended those were
like yeah no one's calling you raises
we're just like i don't think that gets
you off the hook
right right that's hilarious i love the
angry guy who's like oh you called me
racist
i [ __ ] a black hooker in 84.
they always i was like i wouldn't use
you're not racist but i don't think the
uh the black hooker angle is doing you
any points here
yeah yeah and for the love of god the to
the white guys out there
the argument of why can't i say it why
can't i say the n-word why can't i
it's never going to work so don't even
have the argument
it's just it's a bad hill to die on it's
a bad hill and there's no chance a black
guy is going to go
all right go for it you got me i'm yeah
you turned me around on this
huge thing even if you're right wrong
it's just never gonna work out
you know the white guy at the bar who's
like who's like why can't i say it and
you're like you can just let me leave
first so i don't have
to hate so people don't think i know you
yes yes do it at your own risk
exactly do anything at your own risk
right yeah you can say anything i guess
you can just deal with consequences but
we want to be away from you
yeah yeah it is fascinating watching
some people still just say it out loud
you're like whoa it's like a throwback
it's wild to see it's like seeing a like
a steam engine car you're like what
that's still going look at that either
way it's going away quickly
that's why yeah it ain't the ain't the
train you want to be on
right right and that's why you also make
up new words like they used to be the
word for gay people with an f and now
it's cuck
it's really just a different word [ __ ]
is just that's that's all that is
it's it's not even gay it's like [ __ ]
it's like it's like
[ __ ] or something right [ __ ] was the
old school one [ __ ] was old school yeah
fairy but then it i mean louie had that
bit about it so did carlin
but just how like [ __ ] wasn't
like it didn't mean gay really didn't it
you just called your friends that like
hey come on take that shot
it was just like you're just saying it
because you're you're weak
but it's still like it it's not it's not
the right example
right right right right but now it's
[ __ ] because you can't take a whole
group of people for what you're
right yeah unless it's [ __ ] then it's
okay yeah
yeah that one that one also was a
substitute for a while
yeah that one's kind of universal that's
gonna that's sticking
is it [ __ ] is around forever yeah don't
be a [ __ ]
yeah it's weird that it's a bad thing
because it's like you're out calling
your friend that but that's also what
you're trying to get ah
yes yes and then betty white had that
great quote like why
why is a [ __ ] weak i'd take a pounding
or it takes a pounding you know
yeah that's like it's like too much
information by the way
from betty yeah yeah it's like all right
i appreciate the point i don't want to
picture you uh getting rammed
in the back of it betty white yeah what
do i care i'd like to see betty white
get plowed
would you yeah sure i mean you know it's
a fun image i'm not jerking off to it
but
i'll watch a guy get his head cut off
just for the image you know
yeah i mean faces of death
i'm not i'm not going out and look for
it for it but
if you see a guy on the side of the road
you're like wow
you know paralyzed yeah you gotta look
yeah true these videos go viral for a
reason folks
we talked about it last week with the
hanging the public hanging that's right
people used to show up they used to
gather around a crowd yeah that's what i
never got at the urinals you know
people were like why would you look at
my dick i'm like i'm curious like what
are you gay i'm like no i just want to
see what your dick looks like
it has nothing to do with horniness or
sexuality i don't desire it
i just want to see you got to be you got
to do it casually though
i definitely have to do just look i'm
like come on dude the dude's just like
staring right now
with the glasses how about when you're
at you're peeing next to a guy who's
like six
nine and they're just like looking down
you're like oh this is oh that's the
worst
yeah it's all pervert that's a that's a
character
that's a sketch tall perv how about the
kid who had the uh mirror on his shoe
whoa oh that was big damn yeah i went to
a co-ed
high school oh okay with uh i went to a
catholic school so the skirts were there
oh wow yeah so this is pretty porn
internet damn
i didn't do it but that was a thing and
then another big thing was the
walking upstairs and a lot of guys would
look up yeah that was a big one yeah
as long as you're not doing the porkies
jam your dick through the hole and then
shower right that gag did not age well
no
no but his dick had a mole on it which i
related to
i got the mole do you oh yeah it's not
three-dimensional
it's more of a freckle i'd say a freckle
yeah
yeah so my dick would be ruined in a
lineup yeah you know like
that hides the other uh the other marks
on your penis
yeah all the warts and blisters and
herpes yeah
should we do it should we do a sample of
this on the air we gotta we gotta tell
the folks at home what the hell this
is we got so mark and i are in the
process of making
our own rye which is very exciting shout
out to christopher for sending us
all these uh from the distillery i feel
like i might have forgot one but
maybe not i guess it was only six but
yeah we got
should we just let's start with one
right so this is what we're gonna be
selling potentially here we gotta find
one we like but
we'll we'll do it we won't do it too
long but we should at least try this
should we yeah
give it a go let's do it and let's do it
professional different cup for each one
and uh you can see the difference in
color this one's a little darker that
one's super light right here
these were sent to my apartment uh so i
did smell
some of them first because i just want
to know we're working with yeah i do
like the smell
of bourbon and rye dude this one might
be an early favorite
in terms of smell just up should we
should we not go with it first son
yeah save it save it but it's gonna be
tough because we gotta
are we spitting are we swallowing how
are we doing this let's just take a
little sip so we don't get too [ __ ] up
because we're out of them
all right good diversity here this looks
like the the setup at sephora you know
when you gotta do to find the color
palette
all right this one is interesting 2017
rye whiskey this is 95 percent
rye is that good
perfect thank you oh man this is so
exciting
cheers buddy proud of it this is very uh
adult
so so adult cheers okay this is what was
this this is a hundred percent right
ninety-five ninety-five percent right
2017
good year
a little sweet not bad that's good
that's good
i also want to see how we can mix this i
think this would go well with the
manhattan
yes yes not too much kick but you still
know it's there it's got a little
smokiness
which i i don't and and surry is always
a little spicier than bourbon this is
[ __ ] nice dude oh that's good i'm
i'm i'm already on board with that one
all right maybe i should pour it a
little smaller if we're doing something
we're gonna be doing six shots yeah yeah
good point well
little baby shots here little baby
preemies
but yeah that is good stuff i'm already
in love with that one
i'm worried i'm gonna love them all that
is the problem
um i feel like foster parents here right
right
and i feel like larry king we got six
wives here and
well i love them all did he only have
six i think he had like eight or nine
yeah you might have been king yeah
imagine getting married by by marriage
eight you're probably like
all right what's the difference one more
shot i mean at that point the wife just
like you married seven other women
it's not even romantic it's just like i
don't want them to happen that's a bit
and just think about that alimony though
he must have prenups out the ass there's
no way he's paying off
all those divorces that's brutal wait
this is the one we just had yeah 95 so
let's put that here you hold that we'll
put that in the very good uh category
very good now i'm sorry to all these
rides you got to beat very good
yes sorry we got this is this is a new
cup
this is just 2017 rye whiskey
new cup yeah i got new cups for us i'm
in love
this is 95 rye that's full rye
i guess it's full ride wow okay you got
a full ride to college
all right all right thank you
all right cheers this is number two full
ride
interesting
it's a little sour it's kind of
interesting
yeah what do you think it's not i still
like this one better
i like it but it's not good it ain't
beating that 95
no no this one had a little little meat
to it whereas this one just
is a little more paint thinner-y it's
here and it's gone
like my biological father you'll also
love ride
[Laughter]
all right so this is what we just had so
this one's out ah it's out i'm sorry to
say
this is like the bachelor this is crazy
but it's fascinating that it's just this
has
95 that's full and it's so much
different
i'm worried that we're going to have to
this might be a dream we might leave
here drunk because
there might be a showdown at the end oh
that's right that's right or a man down
because uh this could put me on my ass i
got four shows tonight
oh [ __ ] i got three and i got our boy
salaccus following me around
well at least you got a dd this is a
canadian whiskey i'm not too high on
this first off because i want
an american i want our [ __ ] to be
american we're american good point
good point yeah [ __ ] tim horton
[ __ ] over here
come on what the hell's a mountain
should we still try it though
of course we got to try it perfect pour
that was perfect we'll go little on this
one because we're not that enthused on
it anyway sorry canada well it's the
canadian uh
conversion rate it's a little less
cheers
cheers
it's got a kick already just in my
nostril
ah it's not good no it's trash trash
just like poutine
who's that who is that uh mayor who was
a crackhead trudeau
oh uh moore he looked like farley
yeah that's what this is this is trash
yeah who is that guy reed ah
he was he was hilarious fat guy
farley was alive he would have been
perfect that would have been like an snl
oh completely oh my god let's get take
the place of the water so
thank you all right all right what else
we got here
that one kick this one i think is gonna
be good this is
malted uh 51 rye and
malted barley oh boy oh boy
yeah smells pretty good we'll see all
right i like i tend to like it darker
so these seem to be darker that that
canadian would sound like my
ex-girlfriend
that canadian was way too pale
what the canadian one was too yeah that
was like albino yeah
that was some [ __ ] smells good
not bad interesting not bad that's
different
what was this one again this was 51
rye and malted barley i still think that
one's in the lead though still the
winner
easily it's good mm-hmm i'll get it
different
ah damn this is tough because we're not
aficionados we just like alcohol yeah
yeah like
we're not i'm not even like this isn't
exactly sideways where we're like
yeah we're swishing it getting the nose
in there but
we also got to think about the folks at
home like what would they like and i
think that i think people would like
that
this one has the best flavor
goes down easy yeah all right what are
we on here i'm like my ex
you can use that for almost anything
really seems to care
man best movie meet wally sparks is so
[ __ ] ah
so funny somebody uh tweeted at us or
instagram back to school
like i i'm loving it off your wreck oh
dude that movie is that's one of the
best comedies of all time
oh yeah so this is maybe number two so
far really
i think so i think so too it's it's
different all right
i'm gonna do a little palette again yeah
get it good now we'll share the water
this one is thirty six percent rye
and it's a bourbon i didn't think we
were on the bourbon train but i guess
we're giving it a shot
this is bourbon and rye yeah i didn't
know you could
mix and match i thought they were two
separate things that's perfect yeah yeah
we don't need to get too [ __ ] up yet
yeah we got big nights ahead of
ourselves let's see it smells all right
i don't know is this interesting to
anyone i have no idea i can't tell i
mean that's we're going to keep it
pretty short yeah
is this terrible what we're doing right
now he's sleeping
all right all right uh hey people watch
guy fieri wolf down uh
chili dog for six hours you know i don't
love this one uh-oh
i thought i would
it's bitter it's interesting but it's
not like it's a little too bitter for me
yeah it came in good and it it didn't
last i if i was like oh i like yeah i
don't like it
yeah this one's tough it's tough it it's
like it feels like a punishment
yes yes that's a a face turner you know
that
that ain't it grandma's cough medicine
kind of one i feel like so
out of the gate that is killing it we
have one
this is the number one contender right
here oh yeah
this one i'm worried could unseat the uh
one in the first place
okay i'm putting the king back on his
throne here but we'll see
can he beat the king
i wish they had names or something
wouldn't that be nice
well we're naming them that's why they
don't have names yeah good point so this
is baby let's do it we'd say like this
is michael tito
jermaine or are we to wayne's brothers
all right there we go this is the
longest we've made without you farting
here we go that's pretty good that's
pretty good
it's pretty good oh no now we got to try
it back to back
you know what this has a nice finish it
does have a good finish
not a lot of kick ah good band
not really they're terrible damn this is
all right let's keep it
don't finish that because we might have
to do a a taste off now
damn that's good what is that rye
whiskey 51
so this is ryan bourbon which is kind of
our two loves
melding is that so this is this is
ryan uh this is looks like ryan corn
oh ryan corn hmm okay
we know nothing 95 proof that's pretty
is that a lot no not really it's
standard i don't know the proof they're
both 95.
no that's pretty standard for ryan i
think all right
damn so should we do the 95 now again i
want to try that one again yeah let's
give it a good i still have the cup
do you yeah it's the same i'll give you
an i better give you give me a new one
i'll tell you
you're right you know i grew up in the
depression
tell you my hair i love those rodney's
i got no respect i'll tell you i used to
share a
locker with a mop i'll tell you no
respect at all
my mother never breastfed me she told me
she liked me as a friend
all right so i got jogging naked down my
street so what are you doing
you came home early that's a classic oh
yeah that one took me a second
i remember here i think i you know you
know you're drinking too much when you
when you take a piss and you see an
olive i'll tell you
my ex-wife was so fat i dropped a uh
i dropped a drop of water in her belly
button heard an echo
cheers all right here we go back to
number one again
ah that might be the winner man that's
so sweet it wins again it's
so smooth it's the other one was a good
good contender but
this is the winner i got to remember
which one
how funny would that be if we just had
to redo the whole thing
just got badly yeah this is the one i
think wow i write it down winner winner
that's it for sure you think i think so
i mean to me it's
that's smooth it's leaps and bounds
ahead
country mile so this could be detour
or fat cat or fat cat we'll see
damn that was that was fun that was fun
thanks thanks for
going to that journey with us i've seen
people do it i never thought i'd be
doing it myself and it's very exciting
damn all right we're gonna have our own
whiskey look at that
i wish the folks at home could taste it
but you will at some point yeah i mean
that's the whole point we're trying to
so you could try and we want something i
mean this is smooth i have a little bit
more
yeah i got a little hair too that is
very good that's a sipping whiskey
that's a sip we want this to be able to
you i wanted a whiskey good sip you
could shoot
that you could throw in a cocktail yeah
that is good stuff
2017 folks and it's kind of
i think it'll taste even better in a
glass i feel like we should get glasses
for this [ __ ] but
damn that's nice that is nice and i'm
glad we did it we tasted it like
even if our friend chris who's doing all
this for us
if he said i got it for you i'll i'll
figure it out i'm i'm an
aficionado we'd probably go okay
whatever you think but i'm glad we
actually picked it yeah i mean
we're a small part of the process but
we're part of it yes
yes here here damn good stuff that must
be hard to like pick a kid to adopt
that's true i can barely pick a menu
item yeah but like i bet it's hard if
you're at the store you're like yo do
you think they do it like this they're
like
[ __ ] these let me get those last two let
me look at him one more time
yeah let me hang out with him a little
bit see if i like him see if he mixes
well with friends
[ __ ] that must be crazy hard yeah even
picking a dog is hard
you know you got to go to the kennel and
look at them did you have you ever done
that
i have as a kid yeah we picked a dog and
or we would just get this
the stray like bring the stray in you
know or you find the one
at the walmart in the box yeah there's
always a lady with like eight puppies in
a box
i had a friend growing up he just always
had pets and he would just keep
his mom was [ __ ] a little nuts and
she would just
keep adopting these adorable passes and
then get rid of them once they got older
because she was like she's like well no
we were i was like what happened to that
dog she's like we got a new dog
it didn't die it just wasn't cute to her
anymore oh that's horrible
[ __ ] insane that's insane i think i
shouldn't do that with your friend
you're not cute anymore you got acne you
got a boner get out of here
you're 13 he's living on the street yeah
yeah got a better version of me in there
right that could be a bit too yeah
because we all know that kitten and that
puppy i mean you can't beat it but
you know you grow to love it then you
don't want to my uh our cat
is uh was we were both out of town so we
let a friend watch it
you come home it's it feels a little
bummery you're like i usually get
greeted at the door
i got something to pet i can rub the gut
you know and it was weird it was it felt
the house felt very empty without it
damn so the cat wasn't as warm to you
because you'd been gone
no no it's it wasn't home like we had to
go get it but you pull up at home
and there's nothing there it's just a
dark house
they animal add so much energy to the
place
yeah is it hard to work when the cat's
there you sometimes i get the computer
and the cat will like jump on your lap
or something a little but it's cute and
it's fun you go hey get out of here you
weirdo
and then it kind of bats at your hand
like ah it wants to play but then it
just sleeps for the rest of the day so
it's kind of nice
does it does it stick its butt up for
you to pet yes
and you can feel it pushing against your
hand which is like so flattering you're
like you want it
yeah like a horny man just sticking your
butt yeah
oh we've all done that with the
girlfriend how are you laying in bed you
put the boner in the back she's like
jesus christ
this is all these are your moves this is
how you let me know you want to get laid
cats are cool man i really think they're
like they get no love it's all people
should be
i'd see comics go up there and be like
cats
i'm like you're [ __ ] sheep how about
that yeah you're all sheep
cats are like dane cook it's oh you're
it's cool to dislike him
you know yeah and you're like nah he's
actually a talent and
uh he just blew up really big so people
like to see him fail but
uh yeah i don't know this is good
qualities
and i don't want the dog i don't want
the guy jumping up on me all day long
i like the things sleeping on the
windowsill dogs want a lot of attention
this is pretty good
pretty damn good this is nice if we can
just sip on this
that canadian that was terrible i would
not let that over the border that was
the worst canadian since celine dion
yes no that was that was terrible and
neither of them have full body
but she was uh notoriously anorexic
celine dion oh yeah if you pulled a
photo she had a much older didn't she
marry her manager wasn't i think so i
think so he's much older
yeah canadian a lot of talent out of
canada oh yeah bieber
uh where you are you [ __ ] open with
bieber out of all the people
there's so many people to pull from and
you're like yeah yeah bieber yeah
well and the comedy world alone it's
like norm
uh leonard cohen oh lena cohen yeah
montreal uh seth rogen michael sarah
canadian mike myers no isn't jim carrey
from jim carrey this is drew carey
yeah yeah jim carrey amazing canadian
uh colin quinn once told me a story
about norah mcdonald that uh like
leonard cohen used to go see him at a
club in
in montreal leonard cohen like norm are
you kidding me and uh
yeah and quinn's like yeah he would go
see norm or the clay just liked watching
me that was really funny
and norm had no idea who he was nor that
he'd care
like he just didn't give her [ __ ] wow so
i guess like he brought it up to once he
was like oh yeah that guy yeah his music
sucks or whatever
wow like like i love leonard cohen man
but uh it's hilarious that norm was like
yeah [ __ ] that guy like country that's
what he said
that's funny that's what colin quinn
told me wow yeah norma i mean this
sounds
weird but maybe eight years ago over
dalia
he was a vine star at caroline and
bieber was in the audience
really yeah he didn't see my [ __ ] but uh
he wouldn't like me anyway but
yeah he was like a huge hebrew was
probably the oldest
[Laughter]
that's the joke of the night right there
but yeah crazy
damn and that was like bieber you know
now beaver's weird with dreadlocks and
you know driving a
ferrari no no no that's so weird
bieber uh i remember there was like a
video of him playing ball with his like
entourage and he's like lighting them up
and you're like you know none of them
get to play their a game again
of course of course you've got to let
them out i was like damn bieber you
[ __ ] you got the skills
man they zoom back if the basket's like
5-1
you know he's dunking they'd lower it
uh can you can you hit the rim i've
dunked like twice
i'm six three i should be able to
dominate that's impressive though yeah
but they were
they were [ __ ] i can't jump dude i i
have no hops
yeah i'm not when you love hops hops
look fun
yeah it looks so fun just a guy jumping
over a fence
you know just no hands i have fear too
you can't have fear like i'd be scared
to go through the lane
and uh and try to dunk it because if you
fail it's so embarrassing no i mean like
i think i would get injured or something
yeah you can't like i see people do that
like in pickup games i'm like you're not
scared you're gonna like
tear it an achilles or something right
right i'd be so scared to uh
you know go for if i could do that to go
for it and uh because people
just foul you in in street games that's
true yeah and not going down on a
hardwood floor you're going down on
[ __ ] concrete concrete you're gonna
really get hurt like i'll go down just
me going full speed and i'm not that
fast and i'm like [ __ ] that hurt
yeah my friend plays he's like a jewish
guy he's 510 and he's like a big
ball guy he gets elbowed in the face
constantly like all that
you know like checking and he just
handles it i'm like that would that
would bother me for the day i'd be like
dude you helped me in the face
you know like i would be the guy
reasoning like what the [ __ ] was that
but he just handled it but it's very
impressive that's why you got to play
with like all comics because they all
just know not to hit you in the face
like we're all trying to be on tv yeah
yeah yeah
that's true but man when when some like
scary
street tough guy elbows you and you're
like what was that and your nose is
bleeding and he's like
what do you mean i didn't know i didn't
do anything like that's not fun i used
to play with amy's uh husband chris
chris he's a good basketball player and
great chef great yeah
but we would we would play and uh i
remember one time we played with this
dude he was like unhinged
like oh no completely out of his mind
like he could [ __ ] play
yeah but he was just like we walked in
as some guy he
some guy's like [ __ ] you and he's like
walk away [ __ ] walk away and i was like
that was that guy's teammate like that's
how we talked to his teammate
yeah he's that crazy so like he walked
the guy he's like i'll [ __ ] you up
i'll [ __ ] you up and then chris i guess
we're on his team now i don't know
and we played with him and he was just
like just [ __ ] on us the whole time
i'm like hey man
and you can't like pull them aside and
be like hey i do better with
constructive criticism i don't do well
exactly but he was just out of his
[ __ ] mind and uh
chris has told me like he's played in
some of those games with like
in la with like big names like playing
the game with kanye once
wow and he said kanye calls goaltending
in like a celebrity league
which is to me like none of them can
jump that high that's [ __ ] hilarious
what is goaltending because i only know
it from nba jam
oh it's like you can't get the ball uh
as it's coming down
oh so that basically means people are
they're blocking like over 10 feet like
they're getting that high no one is
jumping out
or you can't like if it's off the
backboard you can't like hit it out
you've got to let it go in oh
so it's on the way down into the basket
yeah you can't just swap you got it got
it that makes sense yeah you got to get
on the way up
oh yeah all right i never knew what that
was and i always pretended to
yeah yeah i got you i got you with
sports terms man
i still can't believe he played with
tracy morgan but uh
i played with him no i'm joking about
the the crazy guy
i sat behind him at a game once yeah it
was me and uh anthony devito and we were
like we got
courtside tickets we're sitting behind
him that's the show dude
it was it was crazy yeah dude he was so
funny wow
michael beasley for the knicks went off
and he and tracy morgan just kept
turning
around and going real animals eat meat
and we're just like what i don't even
know what that means
we just like what do you do you just
have to be like yeah dude high five
we're like yeah
you don't even tell me your comic i'm
sure that would be a whole night
you a comic get in here come on make me
laugh you're like no no no no no i'm
just watching the game he is tracy i
mean he is
the third character it's amazing when he
would sit at the cellar he'd be at some
table just screaming at everybody
you like walk by like don't don't scream
at me you know and you're i'm supposed
to be here i'm working at the comedy
club and i'm like oh [ __ ]
thank god he made it thank god he's okay
that would be [ __ ] tragic dude
oh at the walmart yeah yeah yeah holy
[ __ ]
of all the companies like i think about
all the companies to
do to crash into someone and then of all
the people to crash into
right it's like the biggest company and
the most hated company crashing into the
most beloved
community like who doesn't like tracy
morgan i know and the most outspoken
loud eccentric guy you know that guy
will say anything
so you better give him the money can you
imagine being at walmart you're like
all right who did we hit like you're
going to kill me
right have you seen 30 rockets like oh
[ __ ]
and thank god you got hit by the biggest
you know you don't want to get hit by
uh you know uh jill's ice cream
you know or whatever it is you know uh
what do you call that we have nothing
will an apology do mr morgan yeah we'll
donate 20 to blm
[Music]
what is that uh what does that word with
it it's always nice food and it's like
this is
it's very hipstery and and organic it's
rustic artisanal
okay what
look it up i've seen it all over the
place especially in brooklyn
yeah artisanal cheese that's got to be
something about like homey or homemade
or something
like that or they they take pride in it
or that no one was harmed well everyone
takes pride in their food no one's like
rob ford that was the guy's guy he looks
like if tom arnold [ __ ] farley
huge man yeah artisanal that's one of
those words that got
non-mechanized non-mechanized what does
that mean
traditional oh so that means they made
it like
with the mortar and pestle and they
churn the butter
i see that's pretty cool so amish or
artisanal
hmm because there's no machines i just
did a show in amish country
what yeah dude whoa what was that like
it was great it was like at the
local theater it's hilarious it was i uh
i had shopping with me it's hilarious
when you do these gigs and
uh they were very nice the crowd was
great the theater is really cool
but it's funny like the other you see
the other things they show in the
theater
and it's like a it's like a hometown
version of beauty and the beast
whoa like i'm going up against i'm going
up against beauty and yeah
yeah like it's [ __ ] that's tough
because everyone in the town goes
because their wife is in it their kid is
in it so you gotta go
yeah it's like a gimme for an audience
it's also hilarious that it's like
for the people that did not know me
there they're just like we thought this
would be like a family thing
oh yeah my whole riff on it was like but
really what i'm saying is less offensive
than a woman [ __ ] an
animal so that's true that's true
yeah and a gay candle for some reason
but
uh you know it's always a bummer when
you do some big theater and you see all
these signatures on the wall and you're
like this place is from 1908 and you're
like oh baby
we're gonna get some carlin some chaplin
some prior and it's like
the beauty of the beast cast or othello
come on i don't want that signature i
want lenny bruce or something
right but it's all the time hey this is
a
technicolor dreamcoat like all right get
out of here
it is cool when you see like bands that
went through there yeah oh [ __ ]
yes i did something oh i did the
paramount in austin they're like chaplin
played here and you're like wow
so crazy that thing chaplin in 1911 or
whatever the [ __ ] it is played there
that's pretty badass yeah fun story
about chaplin
english guy i believe chaplain i think
he's english
oh i got a good there man i think he's
english he seems so american and he's
not i thought he was jewish he's not
jewish
he's a british cat yeah where is he from
i'm embarrassed i don't know this
i know no one no one talks about how
he's british but
uh i hope i'm not wrong here by the way
somebody said are you jewish and he said
i don't have the honor
big fan of the uh the heebs yeah yeah
and you don't hear that every day
anymore i know i know
old school yeah he's from london hey
there you go
and he died in switzerland ah
and he was married to an 11 year old i
believe what something like that
i don't know this [ __ ] at all oh i guess
i don't know that much about him i'm a
fan i'm about to start a united artist
you probably should say you're a fan
after the 11 year old
it's a long time to show that you're on
board yeah yeah
but uh my point is you're old but for
real
no i think 14 but still not good
you know it was the 40s or whatever it
was a different time geez
uh so he he was doing vaudeville
obviously trying to make
his way and the marx brothers are out
like this is some omaha
sticks wherever there's doing vaudeville
getting chased
barely getting paid and groucho was like
well let's go i'm gonna go see who's
playing at the town over whatever had to
kill a day and he said he saw this kid
and it was unbelievable he's like
this was the best show i've ever seen it
was just some 14 year old kid juggling
oranges and falling and he's like
this kid's phenomenal it was chaplin and
no one knew he was
and no one knew who he was either but so
he was into 14 year olds too
that's crazy man that what a story i
think they were both young but yeah
that's wild the marx brothers story is
such a movie i read their book i'm like
this is a movie i don't know
enough about the marshmallows i know
you're obsessed with graduate tell me
about it i mean
the mom was a singer so they came from a
musical family lived in the in a [ __ ]
box in the upper east side
poor jewish people immigrant parents uh
the mom pushed him into a musical act
they hated it
chico whatever his name was a pool shark
a hustler
um groucho was like a piece of [ __ ] they
were all just like
street kids wow and they got into it and
performed an act and at one point they
were singing
and they ran out of songs or something
happened and they just had to tell jokes
to like kill time
and it killed and so they're like we'll
just do this wow
i didn't want to sing that was their
fallback yeah fall back and it worked
out and
everything in their life came from
falling ass backwards into something
nothing was planned you just had to
you had to survive back then wow so
we'll adapt whatever we got to do
grease paint he wore a mustache he
couldn't find it one night so he just
put grease paint on that stuck and uh
he he got his name because he was a
poker player and you have a thing called
a grouch bag
and that was they were calling him cheap
like go groucho over here
he won't pull money out to play more
poker and so that's where he got groucho
harpo played the harp obviously but yeah
crazy
just fist fights and anti-semitism and
running from gigs like
these hillbillies would chase with guns
and they would try to run to catch the
train i mean
crazy [ __ ] and then they made it and
they were the biggest thing
in in the theater world and then uh they
got then the movies came out and that
was over
it's so interesting like i hear stories
like i like we think we had tough gigs
and then you hear like bill hicks in an
interview like they chased us out of the
bowling alley with guns and i'm like
yeah
you lost me at bowling alley i [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that's true that's true
towns you never heard of yeah you got i
mean comics will [ __ ] on bill hicks
sometimes but it's like
you know he did the rounds man he paid
his dues
yeah he was he had chops like oh yeah
people
[ __ ] on it's like bill hicks went to the
bad areas like he was doing those like
liberal bits
in alabama yes yeah he was doing smart
jokes to dumb people
and he said he felt like an alien so one
of his tours was called like the space
space tour or something the ufo tour the
fine saucers flying saucer yeah
which meant like they don't even they
stare at me like i'm a weirdo yeah i'm
just talking up there but man yeah he
was a beast
yeah he was awesome man so crazy that's
fascinating about groud i didn't know
that that was the origin of his name
i don't know why it won't won't no one
will make a movie out of it just
crazy life story who would play groucho
oh
that is the question i don't know that's
a tough one probably to be like an
unknown
yeah i don't know it might have to be
because you don't want some
regular or star [ __ ] that up
i don't know maybe how about the guy who
played
uh how about like romney malek that guy
who played oh
that's pretty good i didn't think the
bohemian rhapsody movie was good but i
thought he was incredible
he was amazing i totally believed he had
aids
he was incredible that was weird how he
in that scene in
in the movie where he goes uh he told
him that he he uh had a's and he goes
i got it i got it that's what i call it
it's like it yes like that's also what
they say when you've got
that it factor right that kid's got it
and he's like i've got it you're like
damn right you do
you've got it buddy that's funny yeah
it's so true it's like goldman's bid
he's like
we love [ __ ] so much that we have a
birth control we call it the pill
there's a pill that cures polio that's
not the pill this is the pill damn
i mean goldman's on another level gary
goldman look him up guys if you haven't
seen gr the great depression on hbo
oh yeah gary goldman great comic great
he's got a couple netflix too
his albums are great yeah he's killer
but his most recent is the great
depression
yeah yeah and uh as he would say top of
his game
he really is he's great and i think he's
got a new hour that's killer
i i would believe it he's got like a 20
minute chunk on chipotle that's
just like incredible incredible like to
pull that much comedy
out of this chain fast food restaurant
yeah i love it
he was my he wrecked me at the comedy
cellar back wow he was my wreck
to get me an audition at the comedy
cellar so damn
i i opened from magooby's uh joke house
in like 2011. yeah and and he was
i got off stage i was like nervous he
would think i was funny and he goes
you're gonna be my first comedy seller
actually first thing
i got on but you're so beaten down
at that point of your career when you're
featuring that you're just i was just
like that's nice i'll believe it when i
see it yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right wow that is the coolest
i've never heard of a wreck like that
crazy right crazy i barely had that guy
we knew ryan hamilton was a mutual
friend of ours so ryan would
uh say to me like he's like oh you guys
are going to love each other like
you know i think they lived together at
that point yes yes so he
uh i think was like oh you're gonna like
sam and and said the same obviously
tell me about him huge compliment from
that guy like that guy's such a great
writer look him up folks because he's
not the biggest comic but he should be
way bigger
he's doing pretty well though i mean i
mean and he's uh
i mean i think he's playing pretty big
venues now and like
his stuff is very cerebral like it's
meant to be seen and like a
it's weird when i see some comics from
like they're meant to be seeing a club
some guys are meant to be in a theater
gary's meant to be in a theater a
complete
complete theater act yeah i mean i'm
getting
[ __ ] with clubs yeah and i'm nobody but
i started seeing the waitress
i was at a club recently and the
waitress was louder than the audience oh
it drives me nuts and i kept getting
louder to drown her out
she got louder you know i was like what
are you doing we're fighting for them
are we fighting for the floor yeah that
drives me nuts most clubs are pretty
good about that but every once in a
while you run into someone you're like
hey man i am trying to talk up here yeah
yeah yeah this is the show that they're
paying for
so let me do it you wouldn't i always
say you wouldn't do that during hamilton
right well they don't serve drinks
during hamilton yeah that's an
intermission
or check spot or chicken fingers there's
none of that and so
it kind of it's what's beautiful about
comedy and also what's
cruel about comedy is like we're always
kept in check
hey the buffalo wings are more important
than you
i know you think you're some artist but
we got to keep the lights on
and you're like yeah you're right and it
keeps you humble but you're also kind of
like
what do i what are we doing here this is
the system we've worked out
also in the age of venmo and bluetooth
and digital like we got to sit there and
go hang on i got to give this guy a
check for the mai tai and he's got to
fill it out and hand it back to me
and that's all ruining your act like i
don't know it just feels
dated to me are you playing them as
making my ties you're playing nicer
venues in me i think
i could i needed a specific drink it was
probably more of a long island let's be
honest
but yeah the long island iced tea the
death drink yeah
that's one i'll never drink on here
you'll never see me drinking a long
island iced tea
because i like alcohol too much right
right the long island is
is basically like i just want to get
hammered
i don't care what it is what it looks
like how i'll feel tomorrow
let's just get get me feeling better now
it's like the depression drink
yeah it's like i want to take i want to
take a walk you want to beam yourself to
a hangover
right right i wanna i wanna i'd like to
walk to the hangover and have a nice
scenic view and have some experiences
you just want the hangover yeah i know
you just want to escape
you want an escape it should be called
the escape yeah which is what you want
to do on long island
it's a great escape the great escape
that's the name of a long island iced
tea
ours are we are our rye so we got detour
yep fat cat yep oh the long goodbye
i love the longer but it sounds a little
depressed it's a little dark yeah like
i'm trying to put myself to sleep here
give me a long goodbye on the rock
sounds badass
it does it really does yeah we've had a
couple other great um
uh options that people throw at us but
uh detour's badass
theatre just sounds cool give me a
detour and i like a one-word
drink too yeah but hey who knows
somebody could throw one at us tomorrow
and
have a huge curveball that's i i'm
thinking about what you're saying about
like
you want some more i'll do a tiny bit
more yeah give me a kiss
just a kiss you never see that one
cause good night i knew you're gonna say
it do you like it yeah of course it's
been a while but
gina davis rock yeah she had something
going back then
craig biarco phone villain oh wow good
pull
he uh there's a line i'm loving it it's
like very uh
it's like snap shane black wrote it so
it's like fun dialogue
but uh she takes a knife out together
and she goes oh
only four inches ah that's great it's a
great line on a villain
what's your wreck this week well uh
i gotta say i don't know if i have one
because this is [ __ ] good by the way
it's so good look we almost killed that
mini bottle
damn yeah uh oh let me i can come up
with a wreck real quick
uh huh [ __ ]
hold on folks salaccus is here i'm sure
he knows 38 rex
um i have not seen the taking of pelham
123 which he says is like one of his
favorite movies the original with walter
yeah
if you like new york movies it's great i
gotta watch that just the old
subway stuff it's killer all right what
the hell am i wrecking here
i reckon uh
oh this is a bad cheesy wreck but i'm
going to do it hit me
well you know we got a couple of hot
dames at home
i did this the other day and i was going
to sound corny but
i walked by a bodega i just bought a
bunch of flowers
put it in the living room table in a in
a vase or vaz
game changer lights up the room she went
nuts
nobody asked nobody you know asked for
it or anything and i just did it
and just got her flowers i just got her
flowers she posted about
it it's a it's a day changer and you
know it's
18 bucks or whatever the [ __ ] totally
worth it
that's that's a good call it's funny
that you say uh because so many guys
were always like i got a flower because
i did something bad i've never gotten
girl flowers because i [ __ ] up i've
only gotten them as like
like let's because that would feel like
a cop out if you [ __ ] up right
right but if you're just doing it that's
a nice but if you but if it's a [ __ ] up
it's kind of like oh you thought this
was good right
make up for that girls are all about the
you thought about me you were thinking
about me i was on your mind you know
which is funny because that's what
serial killers and stalkers do but
yeah it's gonna be on your mind to some
degree if there's newspaper clippings
and uh like pictures on the wall that's
an issue right right yeah so
it goes a long way don't don't let her
ask for it do it before
it's kind of like the the wake up bj you
ever had the girlfriend you're like whoa
you're blowing me this is crazy that's
flowers for us that's
uh that's our flowers yeah ours donut
our gifts doesn't cost any money ladies
one of us is shallow here yeah we just
like you
for your mouth yeah we don't need a
material
you can't do a wake-up uh cunnilingus
can you
nah they're not into that they're not
you gotta move a leg up
but they also have a harder life than us
in terms of like
killers and stuff like being worried
about like you know yeah
so it's like you can't wake someone up
with sex with a woman
girls have to let the vagina here you go
go nuts you know but if you're they they
get a little shifty it's almost like a
like an animal we're like whoa hey
what are you doing down there you know
they're not just like oh look at this
they're kind of skittish right like a
vagina which i get
things could crawl in there you never
know who's groping or whatever so i
think
they're a little whoa where'd that come
from yeah we're like ah this is all i
think about every day every second so
thank you
good point yeah i think you're right
yeah i mean you could wake up with
breakfast in bed you gotta bro i don't
think
i don't think getting eaten out is on
the top of their list as much as it is
with us
breakfast in bed is overrated too though
oh it stinks
you're just like oh yeah i'm in bed now
i wanna i'm not starting my day
right i'm laying down still i wanna i
got coffee in bed is nice
yes yes i'll bring i'll bring matcha or
coffee or something in bed but i'm not
going to like
no no eggs in bed now you're just
sitting up you're stuck there what am i
fdr
my stephen hawking like let's go to the
table and hang out
so now i'm stuck you
yes all right i got the covers on yeah
i'm pale
but yeah you gotta you get an egg you
drop an egg on the comforter that's
ruined
it's no fun it's over yeah i'm big about
keeping the sheets soft too
let's keep them soft yeah soft keep the
room not smelling like sausage yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
all right that's my wreck and i just
pulled that out of my ass and i'm i'm
happy with it
what do you got i got all right so i was
lucky enough to see
uh sunset boulevard again
wow on a big screen wow so that was yeah
so that was great
and uh one of the best movies of all
time if you haven't seen it
i think there was a thing about like
trump uh when
parasite won he was just trying to rile
up his base so he was like
what happened to good movie just he's
just trying to even though parasite was
great i thought
it was great but he should not he's like
what happened to like he's trying to be
like american movies
like gone with the wind i think he's at
sunset boulevard i'm like
all right trump maybe we'll see trump's
uh rotten tomatoes fave five i'll look
at it yeah
yeah yeah but reference too sunset
whatever happened by the way what
happened uh
new movies came out what do you think
happened it's [ __ ] 70 years old what
do you mean what happened they got
they're still available
right we got to go with the criteria
incorrect maybe gone with the win might
not be actually
oh that is not available it's off hbo
max
sunset boulevard is one of the greatest
it's so relevant it's incredible really
oh to me it's like i'm an aging star and
uh
a guy who kind of gives in noir is the
best because it's always
someone going down a dark hole sure and
you know it ain't gonna work out
is sunset boulevard the same as what was
that lady gaga movie
star is born yeah oh that that's an old
movie isn't it that they've made like
four times
yeah but this is different you've never
seen sunset i've never seen it oh my god
mark it's
really moving
yeah no it's incredible it's uh
it's famous because it opens with the
death of the main character
so he's floating in a pool and he's the
narrator oh
no i don't think any film had done that
up until that point and it's got so many
great lines like
one of my favorite lines in the movie
ever goes it's amazing how gentle people
are once you're finally dead
whoa great great great noir
billy wilder yes the great the genius
billy wilder cool yeah okay
all right i'm gonna watch it oh i can't
believe i haven't seen i'm embarrassed
it's incred there's so many great
it's so relevant to now it's a
struggling writer who can't get
something made
yeah and he basically he's hiding from
these guys who are trying to repossess
his car
he's begging everyone for money he's
like i just need to pay off my car even
goes to his own agent
yeah please i just need some i need some
money and the agent basically you know
he's riches on a golf course he's like
look it'll be good for you to have no
car you have nowhere to go and you'll
have to write a play
isn't that [ __ ] crazy how nothing
really changes nothing changes and
anyway he ends up going in the wrong
driveway and it turns out to be
this uh famous has-been actress
who was a big star in the silent film
days but she faded away and it's got
real stars in it
she plays cards with all these former
silent film stars so she does the scene
where she's playing cards with buster
keaton whoa
and uh cecil b demille has got a pardon
it whoa
because she's like i used to work with
him and he's just like i i knew her when
she was a kid and she was
it's crazy wow it's kind of meta it's
it is meta it's very meta it's one of
the best films ever made i highly
recommend it to anyone
if you haven't seen it big wreck big
wreck i've seen it probably five or six
times but
i i not in a couple years and i was like
it's one of those i always have to
rewatch
all right well i'm sold it's one of the
greatest american movies i think
am i overdoing it yeah what did you call
a movie by the way
sunset boulevard okay i thought you said
hollywood boulevard uh hollywood
not even listening get the hell out of
here uh
did you have you seen dave people keep
recommending
on hulu yeah no i haven't seen it all
right pal santino's in it
i've had uh multiple friends recommend
dave and i
i was like i didn't want to watch it
because i'm so sick of that trope like
the nerdy white guys around cool black
guys and he's
trying to speak slang and i hate that
trope
but they're like no no it's not that
it's it's almost like if larry david was
was trying to be in that world like
young and hip
and did you watch it no i didn't watch
it but i i mentioned this a couple of
weeks ago oh did i
yeah yeah [ __ ] okay but uh no watch it
let me know because i might watch it too
all right all right that's it that's a
good one though yeah yeah
cause not a ton of great comedies out
there so people love this one so maybe
i'll give it a whirl
and i'll give you a [ __ ] one more
just do a little lash with me because i
i'm doing a toast all right hit me baby
boy we went through this i think we
picked uh we made the right choice
here this is our our possible i gotta
smell the bottle
oh you can smell my fingers because you
could smell mine too buddy get over here
yeah this is our bottle [ __ ] i'm sorry
salacious didn't get there yeah
yeah there we go all right what's this
uh toast
my toast is gonna be let's see wait i
can't have a toast i'm off bread
all right i'll kill myself good reminder
for my therapist
just about comedy this is the toast
the only thing that uh that can sustain
this is our love for it
so never lose the love for it wow
because there's so much [ __ ] in this
in this business and there's so much
[ __ ] in this game he kept he said to
me the only thing that can sustain this
and that goes for more than just your
career by the way
that goes for your life because you're
gonna you're gonna get more
i mean look you're gonna get you're
gonna get you're gonna have a better
time
going about life if you're just trying
to put out love in the world you know i
completely
agree and now you know the the bourbon
is hitting me
yeah sam's getting sad i'm like why
can't we be nicer man
yeah no but i completely agree my toes
are all over the place last week was to
hitler's good ideas
which was you know a joke yes
we're all joking folks here here no i'm
with you positivity goes a long way
unless it's covered but uh yeah
stay positive don't get bitter and put
out love is what i'm saying too because
yes
because we need to feel the love of
comedy that's what's kept us in it like
the bitterness
right it's so easy it can seep in so
easily
dude i had this conversation i was with
three comics this weekend or two comics
we're all
talking bits writing laughing we would
try the bits then we'd rework them and
tweak them and it was so fun and
we all came together and uh that's what
it's all about we sit here and go
numbers and why is he famous and
you know networks and this and that but
you can still do that but
at the end of it just you got to be like
i'm lucky i like my life
i like that i get to tell jokes yes
we're lucky and that's the thing about
therapy
is you get that [ __ ] out there and then
you go back to the world and
and be positive and happy so get the
negative out with this guy that's what
you're paying for
yeah and let's be honest a lot of people
could get more negativity out
other places sometimes you'll hang out
with people and you're like this guy's
just got a good
that's some negativity i'm getting out
michael
michael go on a poignant rant and then
just go yeah
that's my favorite part of this yeah you
got to mix it up you know
uh yeah so you just got to surround
yourselves with so many good comics last
night like i was
a seller i was hanging out i saw grier
barnes for the first time in like
16 months i missed greer barnes you know
gave me a big hug
i said i'm sad i didn't get to celebrate
the knicks this year with you
you know william stevenson who used to
host the seller all the time
yeah passed away and and greer and
william had a long-standing bet
every year 50 bucks the knicks gonna
make the playoffs
50 bucks every [ __ ] year wow and i
said william had to die the one [ __ ]
year we brought it and
he came in and gave me a hug nice little
hang saw roy wood jr last night
so many great new bits that's a buddy
mayron you like all these like
comics that are fun to see uh jay jordan
just started working yeah yeah he's got
good [ __ ] dude great writer he's really
funny good writer
yeah he's punchy punchy quick that's my
favorite kind of comedy yeah mehron's a
glowing beacon of light it's all good
stuff
we do good we haven't we're in a good
business so let's all try to
stay up as they say cause uh you know
we're all mentally ill too you got to
remember that
deranged yes we're we're pieces of
garbage and with low self-esteem and
weird
past and childhood so yeah let's uh
let's keep it real and positive and you
know what's that uh
you wouldn't show you wouldn't put your
bad breath on someone so why put your
bad
mood on someone yeah a lot of people
have a bad breath on you
yeah but it's horrible i know i know
what if someone with bad breath and a
bad mood is on you that's
the worst you ever meet a depressing
person with bad breath
that's that's a death penalty you know
we gotta get rid of that person
put them in the chamber but i had a lady
today or
two days ago she's like can you sign my
book and i was like yeah sure and as i'm
talking to her or as i'm signing she's
talking to me and spitting on the book i
can see the droplets hitting the book
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing lady like
you know cool it
she was hammered or whatever but you
know if you look down you realize it was
it was a credit card statement you're
like this is [ __ ] hard
yeah that's no dude people spitting on
you
the booze in your face you're like
[ __ ] kill me i know i was jealous my
friend he had glasses i was like at
least you got a like a little bit of a
blocker
you know but i was just getting pelted
with these spit droplets
oh yeah unacceptable do you purell
a little i'm a little over it to be
honest i'm a little over i wash the
hands a lot though
i get sick so much less you know these
days because i've been washing my hands
so much so i'm like why not i also
realized like you're getting
if you just shake i'll shake so many
hands after a show
that i gotta wash like yeah you know
it's just like that's how you get sick
just contact with people right so i'm a
fist bump guy but i uh
i played and literally played in dirt
all day long as a kid and i think it
helped me later in life
yeah yeah oh yeah just i've got a pretty
good immune i don't really get sick
you don't get sick ever no i don't get
sick constantly i know
well you lit you but you grew up in the
city the filthiest place on the planet
yeah what the hell why am i such a [ __ ]
i don't know maybe it's the jeans or the
it's the jeans
it's a bad back yes yes stress all the
time it always goes to
my spine but you got a good frame
six three handsome full head of hair
you're handsome buddy
you know hairy chest now i know this
guy's drunk yeah i know i'm trying to
[ __ ] it
i got a great ending to this we just
have credits going on we're just butt
[ __ ] each other
people like have you seen the end that's
the name of the new ride
that's our clip on youtube on instagram
whatever
yeah it doesn't need captions mark
yeah i don't know i just uh
can't i can't can't get sick i get sick
consciously but i've been better about
it
and uh yeah man i'll tell you i i just
i think the hand washing makes a big
difference yeah the pure health feels
like
some place i think i'm sure it helps a
little but it's like what you're saying
when you're doing all the time like
maybe it
maybe having doing this [ __ ] does
strengthen your immune system i think
i'd be played in dirt i really think it
does yeah over time especially so uh
especially when you're a kid you get it
out you get you get absorbed that [ __ ]
or you absorb that [ __ ] early and it uh
your body just gets immune it's almost
like playing the guitar your fingers get
stronger and and
more calloused interesting yeah that
must that might be it
i think so i think so but you're too far
gone
i'm gone yeah you're already ruined i i
yeah
it's tough what are you gonna do yeah
but hey you gotta live damn it i mean
also we're
killing ourselves with this but this is
good we found our [ __ ] baby ready we
got it
thanks christopher that is i'm that is
smooth
this is like a nice buzz i'm feeling
great i gotta cool it
but yeah feeling good well the prototype
i gave him i said i want this to be like
buffalo trace because
that's affordable but it's a really good
bourbon perfect
comparison i want people to be able to
buy this so it's not too expensive but
it's killer yeah good call i can't
believe he
gave us another swill what were you
thinking we're gonna get drunk on these
two i guess
yeah good point each episode is going to
be worse and worse canadian whiskey in
six weeks
yeah it's stunk why was canadian whiskey
popular in the in the 60s what the hell
were they thinking
i don't know canadian club's all right
it's all right i've had some
bloody shits on that stuff really oh my
god we get the plastic handle that you
you bought at the grocery store i used
to drink it a lot
yeah i did too taka taka's rough
fire water that's the vodka right yeah
that [ __ ] was horrible
always in plastic plastic bottle is like
cereal in a bag
it could be the the same [ __ ] but it
just feels sadder
yeah a plastic bottle's rough i know
you don't want to be able to squeeze a
bottle of liquor you know it's already
poisonous
you're gonna be able to hear your
[ __ ] disease yeah yeah exactly it's
like a dog toy
yeah it gets me running towards you so
many nights isn't it great like our
friend wilson vince
has never drank yeah but we should maybe
he'll drink for an episode
i doubt it that would be dark though i
think he's muslim or something
he's vegan he doesn't eat sugar and it's
like and he exercises a ton you're like
man what does your insides look like
they must be pink and clean
yeah so many years of this [ __ ] turning
me on
i love a pink inside
yeah will so healthy he's like yeah he
i've been on the road with him
we're drinking tonight phil hanley and i
are downing negroni's he's drinking a
green tea at dinner
there you go and that that's over a year
plus yeah i mean
the guy's 54 no 51. 50
okay 50. but he looks amazing yeah no i
was shocked he was 50.
i know i know especially when you see
his accomplishments
all right joking will he doesn't know
how to use a podcast
i do one with him now yeah
but all right we got to wrap this thing
up you got a bit
uh yeah i got a couple ideas i got a few
ideas i don't know what to work on here
uh yeah same i'm all over the place i'm
all over the place dude yeah i could try
i mean we [ __ ] we tried a couple quick
[ __ ] we haven't done ads oh
geez good call because you could tell
we're drunk ah this is hitting hard
should we start out with uh this first
one we might be drunk is brought to you
by honey
yes love honey dude love the honey
we shop online you know we've all seen
that empty promo code
taunt us sometimes spit in our face
thanks to honey i don't have to do that
search for one anymore honey is a free
browser extension that scours the
internet for discount codes
when you're ready to check out honey
automatically applies the best one
instant savings honey has found its
customers over 2
billion bucks in savings supported by
over 30 000 stores online
buy anything from tech and gaming
products to beer and wine
i've saved so much money on this haven't
you of course it's a genius idea i don't
know what took so long this is so
gold you can just punch it in and boom
you got a promo it's great
it's google for promo codes i've
recently bought
some shoes i used honey got a better
deal and you should too
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings
it's literally free installs in just a
few seconds save some dough and support
this podcast
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
drunk that's join honey dot com
slash drunk and get that honey baby
all right should we do a bit well we got
one more ad too
should we do that now let's knock it out
we're already in the zone sheath
underwear
folks i love sheath big fan
i'm wearing it right now they're stained
i know i'm not but i
i i wear them a lot oh they're they look
great they feel great your dick is
in a separate pouch on your balls
finally some space
i love the pouch you don't get that
weird schmeagma in between the two
you know uh it's just great and also if
you're like i tell you to have that
great bit about when you're when you're
fighting with your partner and your dick
falls out a little flat
yeah yeah he just peeks out to see if
there's trouble of brewing
but that's true with sheath that doesn't
happen it doesn't happen everything's
tight secure where it needs to be
supported it's great it's a hot summer
this guy went to iraq who uh this guy
robert who made it so he knows about the
sand and the heat and
it's israel and palestine down there
you've got to give them some space every
now and then
so get the sheath tell them how sammy go
to sheath underwear.com in order with
promo code drunk to get 20
off your first order and sheath
underwear 100
back uh a 100 money back guarantee that
sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
and let them support
your balls yes i really do like it it's
good stuff i love sheath and my my gal
likes it too
yeah they look kind of they look like
you take your underwear off and you're
like oh
this is the type of [ __ ] like a wall
street guy would wear yes
yeah you feel like kind of a man and
chief yeah like a james bond or
something
all right with a bit okay i got a couple
i don't know which way to go
i got something you really that's not
ready
something really half baked all right um
i have one about
um here's an idea i had
um because i get mine is really raw
yeah i got
i had to think about like i was a white
man i obviously have an easier life
but it is funny when liberals like will
talk about
other groups as opposed to white people
like when they'll when they'll say
[ __ ] like uh you know with trans people
she was born in the wrong body okay
there's nothing she can do about you
know but then
uh within the same people pen articles
like attention white men
all of you are [ __ ] right right and it's
like well what about i was born this way
i know and you can't change race we've
seen a few people try that and it didn't
fly
like not only am i stuck in this body
i'm stuck
she can at least change yeah the only
flaw with this bit right now is that
like
being trans is obviously way harder
that's right that's the one thing
i'm like it's not linear i think that's
maybe the issue with it
i i hear you but at least they have an
option they have it out
like they it's hard and there's bigotry
and whatever but like
they can get out of it like i don't know
i don't feel like a man i'm not a man
inside i'm gonna be a woman
and there's gonna be some options you
can't help how you're born only applies
to people with harder lives
like you can't you were born
i was born an oppressor i was born
oppressor
yeah yeah and you can't change that
you're just stuck you could change it to
a white woman but
a lot of people hate them too but you
stuck with that that
[ __ ] cracker honky skin
yeah you can you're a jew too so you
could change you can convert religion
even but you're stuck with that
no pigment this might be nothing i i
don't know i like
let me try a different one it's very
hypocritical let me try it it is but
it's not
it's just i'm not making a good enough
point yet here's here's the other angle
i had it's it's part of a bigger chunk i
have a joke about like
this is a joke that hits people always
like they ask when you're a mistake
i tell people you know i was a mistake
and they go you know
broken condom are unplanned and i'm like
gee i never broached the topic with my
mother because i love her like i can't
imagine pouring my mom aside like hey
uh broken condom or raw dog what
happened mom
i know you're crying but my friend gary
really wanted to know that's why i
ruined our relationships right
so that that is and i want to add to it
like a part where i almost defend my
biological father for leaving because
like hey it wasn't a good deal for him
he didn't want to have a kid not only
did he have a kid he's got one who's uh
always on tour [ __ ] on him in joke
form
like that's so the opposite of what he
wanted right he wanted nothing he's got
a living thing that resents him in witty
ways
publicly publicly broadcasting
microphones woody is not right that's
well you're basically doing a campaign
for how shitty this guy was
going all over the road like i'm going
to syracuse to talk about this deadbeat
yeah you know and he's like [ __ ] the
whole point was to not
for you to not be here yes i really got
not what i wanted yeah no one is
pro-abortion more than your dad he's
like i should have done that
what the hell was i thinking if they
made a time travel movie
it's like it's like terminator but he
just goes back to to kill me
right right you're gonna kill hitler's
baby no no mine
he goes back in time he just he just
tries my mom again he's like
let me pitch it to you one more time
this kid's gonna be really shitty
i'm from the future also he's got a good
reason like this is why i left
this is a nightmare no wonder i didn't
want to be a dad do you mean a dad sucks
i'm not even there and i'm getting
trashed
that's [ __ ] funny ah that's great
that's a lot right there all right what
do you guys think the trans thing is
good too
uh i love you because you believe in
like i believe in that when you have
comic friends you need the ones that
aren't the ones like
i love joe mackey but it's like to death
i run a bit by him and he's just like
oh that was terrible and i'm like i need
someone who sees
the upside and the potential i see the
potential for sure
what do you got and i think almost any
bit can be fixed but
obviously there's some are way far off
than others but yeah
all right so uh my gal has been farting
publicly and getting a little too brazen
about it
which i'm like look i get it you're a
human being with bodily function you
have to fart but
give me a little shame you know like
three times this episode
well hey look it's different i mean for
genders you know like
i hate to say it but it is and my point
is
men if i cried openly
i thought my trans bit was offensive
hold on you know i'm right you know i'm
right
i mean there's a reason women are like
let me close the door
let me uh you know do whatever like
they're nervous about looking a certain
way
women don't really curse as much they
don't talk about [ __ ] as much no i'm
listening
all right so look if we really want
equality let's go for it but look if
you're if a boyfriend starts crying
every day
that's weird yeah like i okay his mom
died or whatever
cry i get it but like if you're just
openly weeping
it's the same thing as the farting it's
the girl's version
wow that's good aha okay if the guy
cries every day you're like this guy
sucks i get it if he needs to cry every
now and then but
every day at home at home openly at home
come here let me give you a ride right
out in public [ __ ] i gotta deal with
this now i guess
yeah maybe it's the same for farts and
it's completely the same with farts and
and when i do cry there's a little shame
up so i gotta
look away you know and that's how the
farting should be like oh
[ __ ] that was slipped i had some uh you
know
pop-pop either way just hold it in
yes yes and then one of my punches is uh
yeah like either way you obviously have
something bigger
brewing inside you oh you know like
she's got a [ __ ] or i've got a you know
family thing or whatever it is but uh it
needs more but i think i think this
the comparison is something the farting
and crying clear the air
yeah that's good let's clear the air oh
harry's out but yeah i think the the
comparison
if it matches i just gotta find the
punch lines
yeah crying for a man is farting for a
woman
you know this is why women are like they
don't just [ __ ] with the door open i'm
like
i'm a woman i'm not gonna do that that's
why we're both [ __ ] up for different
reasons
what do you mean well men are [ __ ] up
because we hold too much yes
right and then we snap and and kill
people
women are [ __ ] up in a different way
men are mad shooters because
they hold their pain and then one day
they just [ __ ] snap right
whereas women are just kind of mean
right
right or that's what let me cry at work
or something right
but like i'm talking about like yeah
women can cry and men help
women fart people go away yeah men cry
people go away
right away you left your own devices
with that
that's very interesting yeah cause we've
all seen a lady and you're like what's
up with her like
uh lady stuff she's going through
something and you're like i'm going
through a ton
but i held it but it's just we're
different you know i like you comforting
you're like come here
oh hold on come here baby sorry
yeah yeah and uh one of the lines is uh
hey
boyfriend farts that's a dry panty
girlfriend farts
that's a wet painting all right
somebody gave me that line that's not
mine but yeah
i thought that was fun but all right i i
like the what did you just say you had
something that i liked
just now literally i've had like five
five of these drinks what are you
oh you just said it damn it what did you
say you're sober about
uh men become mass shooters oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah right right right women
just become kind of mean
yeah i think there's something about
that where like you just that's just
irritating to constantly be holding in
gas
holding and crying is so much worse oh
it's deadly that makes you a shittier
person
right right right yeah exactly i like
how uh
men bottle it in and become mass
shooters women
bottle and just kill you slowly they eat
away
at you you know one person yes yes
men and women they both uh they both
need a safe space for different reasons
like you far and you're like it's fine
right right men you
maybe like maybe a female therapist who
just lets you fart
yeah oh that's funny i don't want to
step on too much of your uh
women kill how they love oh yeah that
was a classic
that's one of my best bets it's a
signature that was a
yeah a game changer bit but all right
all right all right that's good stuff
we gotta go i think we've got an hour
and 40.
oh yeah i'm all over the road in weird
cities
toledo dayton syracuse
uh houston texas
uh what else we got here uh
yeah yeah yeah philadelphia helium
buffalo
um appleton arlington improv
brea in california albany west palm
beach
comedy connection madison wisconsin so
we got some fun stuff coming up and some
weird ones but come out either way
say hello drink one for me what do you
got there sam oh
raleigh cincinnati uh it's like 40
minutes outside cincinnati it's that
funny bone
liberty liberty yeah i got uh madison
okc uh [ __ ]
uh nashville can't wait for nashville
very excited
uh governor's in levittown i got a
comedy off broadway in lexington
kentucky i got uh kansas city missouri
portland oregon baby helium can't wait
uh
comedy cast on royal oak michigan way
more philly
boston go to samrel.com shows we're
[ __ ]
torn it up i'm pumped about this this
ride dude
very pumped i love how good it is it
tastes great like
it feels good to sell something that we
would actually drink that is smooth
so smooth so flavorful it's got a bite
but not too much it's just
taste scrumptious [ __ ] vince vaughn
and swinger smooth
yeah that's money baby let's do it all
right well keep listening
sign up for the patreon uh see us on the
road
yeah follow the follow that we might be
drunk on on instagram
yes leave us reviews too we never asked
people to do that but you should do that
on apple if you can yeah leave a review
five star
comment post say hello share and watch
our specials on youtube [ __ ] it
and uh yeah tell a friend queef it up
and thank you keep drinking